start by talking to Brandon bliss and
find out who told him you were the
toddler unfortunately bliss is not here
probably in the VIP section at a Fat Boy
slim concert would that be cool for 37
year old the functional brother is
timeless aims alright I don't know who
told Brandon but I heard it was someone
on the football team okay well we need
more information than that so take me
back to the day spare no details okay I
saw Brandon after second period and
everything seemed tight
but then when I saw him after third
period something had clearly changed
[Applause]
after that there was little color left
in the world for young Jake my earring
less gold my Jenko jeans less purple are
you sure you are becoming cool yeah why
I know how to solve this we just have to
find out which football player had third
period with Brandon bliss we need his
class schedule yeah but where are we
gonna find that in the coolest room in
the school you could have just picked
the lock oh I'm sorry I'm just so amped
up about admin okay it's got something
oh that's not Brandon's profile it's
mine I just want a quick peek at your
attendance record zero absences oh mama
printing this for later all right keep
in your pants
you